[Musique]
sommes-nous seuls dans l'Univers pour
certains la réponse à cette question est
sans appel évidemment nous ne sommes pas
seuls dans l'Univers mais alors que
beaucoup doutent de l'existance
d'extraterrestre la NASA a publié il y a
quelques mois une vidéo d'un objet non
identifié la fameuse agence spatiale
américaine qui a lancé une enquête
scientifique sur le sujet l'année
dernière a présenté aujourd'hui son
rapport sur les
ovnis welcome alors quels sont les
résultats de leur recherches OVNI
extraterrestre rapport de la NASA les
troublantes révélation de Jean-Claude
Bourret sur les phénomènes surnaturels
ce soir dans
TPMP Jean-Claude merci d'être là parce
que là ça bouge ça bouge ça bouge ça
bouge euh il y a des choses qui sont
tombées là donc là on commence à se dire
que il y a de plus en plus de de de de
chance que nous ne soyons pas seuls on a
vu ce qui s'est passé hier dans TPMP au
Mexique un cadavre non humain de plus de
de 1000 ans voilà et ont été exposés au
public et selon certains spécialistes
pourrai appartenir à une espèce
d'extraterrestre ça déjà sur ça qu'est-
qu'est-ce que tu
dis je n'ai pas étudié le dossier
directement je l'ai étudié par des
correspondants qui étit sur place et la
seule chose que je peux dire c'est que
évidemment ce ne sont pas des
extraterrestres pour une raison ce sont
des alors l'hypothèse des scientifiques
qui sont sur place c'est que c'est un
artefact c'est-à-dire une construction
de quel
qui a pris des des cadavres d'enfants
qui étai déjà enterrés par les Incas
sans doute et qui a fait une une
reconstitution avec un visage qui est
censé être un visage extraterrestrecord
donc voilà on dit que ça ouais donc ça
non c'est une manipulation quoi ce
mercredi 26 juillet David gruch tu
connais David gruch
grusche un agent au sein du ministère de
la Défense des États-Unis il a été
auditionné sous serment face au Congrès
américain devenu lanceur d'alerte il
affirme avoir eu accès à des documents
officiels attestant de l'existence d'un
objet volant non terrestre tu as entendu
tu as entendu ça il affirme que nous ne
sommes pas seul dans l'univers et les
autorités dissimulent les preuves de
l'existence extraterrestre es-tu
d'accord avec lui oui bien sûr parce que
quand on regarde l'histoire de
l'humanité ouais on constate que la
finalité de la matière c'est de créer la
vie la terre à 4 milliards et demi
d'année les premières apparitions d'une
algue unicellulaire c'était il y a
environ 3 3 milliards et demi à 4
milliards d'années et les premières vies
qui sont sorties de la de la mer pour
arriver sur la terre c'est à peu près
400 millions d'années l'homme a 300000 à
400000 ans ce qui veut dire qu'à
l'échelle de l'univers nous venons de
naître nous n'avons pas un passé
historique de plusieurs milliards ou de
plusieurs millions d'années donc notre
intelligence est extrêmement réduite par
rapport à celle d'une civilisation
extraterrestre qui aurait ne serait-ce
que 100000 ans d'avance mais une
civilisation extraterrestre peut avoir 1
milliard d'années d'avance 2 milliards
ou 5 milliards d'années d'avance par
rapport à nous on ne peut même pas
imaginer ce que c'est c'est ti un truc
ti pourquoi les autorités les
gouvernement nous cacherait des des
ovnis alors ça c'est la meilleure
question que l'on puisse poser merci
c'est la meilleure
question d'abord il faut constater une
chose il aura 20/ 20 euh il faut
constater une chose que tout le monde
peut constater c'est
que les États-Unis sont les seuls
actuellement à faire le buzz comme on
dit sur les objets volants non identié
c'est vrai il y a que la Chine n'en
parle pas la Russie n'en parle pas la
France n'en parle pas l'Europe n'en
parle pas personne n'en parle sauf les
États-Unis donc la question c'est
pourquoi s'ils en parlent de façon aussi
précise avec des anciens des services
secrets qui comme par hasard ont
rencontré d'autres personnes des
services secrets qui ont vu la soucoupe
volante écrasé qui ont vu les
extraterrestres tout ça c'est de la
manipulation et tous ceux qui
connaissent l'histoire des États-Unis et
des ovnis le savent il y a eu le projet
Bluebook il y a 60 ans le projet
Bluebook c'était la même chose
c'est-à-dire qu'on a payé des
universitaires pour dire alors il y
aurait des gens qui verraent des ovnis
dites-nous vous qui êtes des savons si
c'est vrai ou pas ils ont fait un un
truc bidon que tout le monde a démonté
dans les années qui ont suivi donc c'est
qu'est-ce qui nous cache la question
c'est qu'est-ce que les États-Unis
veulent nous cacher voilà alors
qu'est-ce que les États-Unis veulent
nous cacher c'est une très bonne
question et je vous remercie de me
l'avoir posé
ouais salut les loulous on est avec
jean-claud Bouret alors je je je ne sais
pas je ne suis pas dans le secret de la
CIA qui qui doit savoir mais je pense
que s'ils font autant de buzz comme l'on
dit sur les objets volants non identifi
avec des réponses aussi insignifiantes
c'est-à-dire qu'ils disent à la NASA
voilà il y a 14 scientifiques qui vont
s'occuper des objets volants non
identifiés comme en France avec le gpan
le gpan ça fait je sais plus 40 ans
qu'il existe il a jamais rien trouvé
donc je pense qu'ils essayent de cacher
quelque chose alors est-ce que ce qu'ils
essayent de cacher c'est tellement
énorme
c'est ça que on ne peut pas le dire tout
de suite à l'opinion publique qui n'est
pas prête parce qu'on voit bien de quoi
est faite l'actualité quotidienne c'est
le sport c'est
l'insignifiance c'est la visite du roi
je veux pas dire que la visite du roi
est insignifiante mais enfin je veux
dire sur les sur les autres planètes sur
les autres planètes la visite du roi
excusez-moi c'est pas la préoccupation
ESS les annes mais vraiment sur les
autres planètes non non je te dis oui
non mais c'est vrai donc toi c'est c'est
quand même si bizarre même tu parlais du
gpan il y a un instant c'est donc une
cellule en France qui s'occupe des des
des des ovnis qui a été créé d'ailleurs
après ma première série d'émission sur
France interre en
1974 ça avait fait tellement le buzz
comme on dit aujourd'hui puisque que
j'avais eu la première
interview internationale d'un ministre
d'État chargé de la défense nationale
Monsieur Robert Galé et Monsieur Robert
Galé m'avait dit avec sur son bureau
tous les rapports ultra secrets de
l'armée qu'est-ce que tu as dit là il
éta venu avec Roger non non mais c'est
vrai fais attention parce que j'ai sur
moi une arme extraterrestre qui qui me
permet de te désintégrer même à 10 il a
raison il a raison alors tu as vu
aujourd'hui le rapport de la NASA
qu'est-ce que tu en penses Jean-Claude
parce qu'il disent il disent euh il a
publié cet après-midi là la NASA il a
publié un rapport sur les objets volants
non identifiés près d'un an après le
début d'une enquête réalisée par des
scientifiques à la demande de la NASA
et la NASA a tenu une conférence de
presse et il y a bill Nelson Montfort
qui a notamment révélé les résultats de
la NASA concernant les ovnis il laisse
clairement le doute plané il dit que
c'est possible qu'il y ait des ovnis
j'aime beaucoup cette phrase il laisse
le doute plané mais tous ceux qui
connaissent le dossier ont des
certitudes bah bien sûr pour dit pas
nous pas seul dans l'univers évidemment
que ces intelligences extraterrestres
viennent de nous visiter et j'explique
dans mon dernier livre les ovnis
voyagent dans le temps j'explique
pourquoi comment c'est possible avec euh
Patrick Marquet qui est un scientifique
de haut niveau qui est docteur en
physique qui a travaillé avec un prix
Nobel et qui explique comment le voyage
dans le temps est possible si le voyage
dans le temps est possible c'est
d'illeurs la seule solution pour
comprendre pourquoi ils viennent nous
voir et pourquoi ils prennent pas
contact avec nous parce que dans leur
temps à eux il s'est écoulé quelques
semaines quelques mois ou quelques
années alors que nous on les voit depuis
des milliers d'années bien sûr oui et
c'est vrai que le patron de la NASA il
va un tout petit peu plus loin parce
qu'il dit je suis convaincu que d'autres
formes de vie existent donc ça ça
accrédite votre tèse c'est-à-dire que
ils disent un tout petit peu et ils nous
prépare à la grande révélation c'est ça
il nous prépare quelque chose je sais
pas quoi mais ça va être ça va être
conséquent non mais vous imaginez vous
imaginez si comme l' dit d'ailleurs r
mched en Israël qui est un scientifique
de très haut niveau je me rappelle qui
dit que il y a des extraterrestres dans
un certain nombre de gouvernement vous
imaginez si on apprend que Macron est un
extraterrestre mais tu RA ah bah là oui
non non mais non mais c'est ce qu'il dit
alors Biden c'est pas un extraterrestre
parce qu'il dort tout le temps mais il
peut y en avoir d'autres il a dit ça non
s rigol oui rched qui est général de Sal
à la retraite maintenant qui est
professeur d'université qui a trois fois
la plus haute distinction israélienne a
dit à la fin de l'année
dernière il a dit nous ne sommes pas
seul dans l'univers c'est une évidence
mais il y a des civilisations
extraterrestres qui ont visité la terre
qui nous ressemblent comme deux gouttes
d'eau et qui sont dans un certain nombre
de gouvernement ce que d'ailleurs MRE
vedev quand il était président de la
Russie a dit J pas au
tennis il peut jouer au tennis aussi Mo
jecla je suis un peu terre à terre mais
j'aimerais y croire évidemment mais j'ai
une question toute simple notamment
c'est pourquoi notamment il y a il y a
un super télescope qui s'appelle Hubble
qui est dans l'espace qui a qui a une
vision il pourrait filmer en gros plan
un poil de cul sur Mars il a jamais
réussi il a jamais réussi à
photographier un seulov un se OVNI et
les seules photos qu'on a c'est un
paysan dans le Gers qui sort son chien
et un iPhone 5 qui prend une photo
pourquoi on n pas de photo double
pourquoi pourquoi ah parce que ne ser ne
sert pas à photographier les poils de
cul de
[Applaudissements]
un télescope qui tourne autour de la
Terre j'aurais préféré que vous me
parliez de web qui est à 100 qui est 150
millions de kilmè de la Terre et qui
fait des photos de poil de cul du soleil
est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'on a déjà pris
une photo d'un enir sur le nombre de
photos des centaines de mil regardez
dans mon dernier livre vous en verrez
des authentiques bien sûr alors je peux
te montrer parce qu'en 2022 la NASA
avait pour la première fois elle-emême
publié une vidéo d'un OV qu'elle é en
train d'étudier on va vous montrer la
vidéo et toujours aucune explication n'a
été trouvée regardez en 2022 la NASA
s'était retrouvé face au même phénomène
un objet sphérique aperçu au
Moyen-Orient toujours inexliqué à ce
jour bien que nous sommes toujours en
train de l'examiner je ne dispose pas
d'autres données que celle-là et il nous
faudra donc du temps pour parvenir à une
conclusion
jusqu'à ce que nous obtenions des
données mieux résolues sur des objets
similaires alors alors JeanClaude c'est
quoi ça une boule de pét c'est du c'est
pour cacher la vérité c'est de
l'enfumage c'est de l'enfumage
évidemment il y a longtemps qu'ils le
savent en 1947 le président des
États-Unis recevait des rapports du chef
d'étatmajor des armées 1947 il y a plus
de 70 ans qui disait les secou Voland
parce qu'à l'époque on appelait ça
flying ser les S Voland sont quelque
chose de réel ce n'est pas une arme
secrète d' quelconque pays de cette
planète vous imaginez bien Cyril qu'en
plus de 70 ans les services secrets
américains mais pas seulement
américains savent ce que sont les Enis
d'où ils viennent ce qu'ils veulent
alors Jean-Claude depuis tout à l'heure
tu nous dis moi moi je ne crois que toi
donc croyez non les ovnis voyagent dans
le temps non mais c'est pas c'est pas ce
qu'il a dit c'était une vane Jean-Claude
est-ce qu' voilà parce que là donc ça tu
dis que c'est de l'enfumage pourquoi on
nous enfume comme ça parce que la
réalité est tellement énorme c'est ça
alors les amis américain c'est une
hypothèse les Américains préparent
quelque chose d'abord sont les seuls à
préparer quelque chose je le répète hein
ni la Chine ni l'Europe ni la Russie ni
l'Afrique ni l'Amérique du Sud ne sont
sur la même longueur d'onde il y a que
les États-Unis pourquoi parce qu'ils ont
ou ils veulent cacher quelque chose ou
ils veulent nous préparer à une
révélation moi j'espère que c'est ça la
bonne hypothèse qui nous prépare une
révélation et j'ai tendance à penser que
c'est la bonne hypothèse pourquoi parce
que déjà il y a 2 ans ils ont autorisé
des anciens pilotes de chasse à diffuser
les fameux
euh film que on a tous vu où il y a des
pilotes de chasse américains qui
essayent de poursuivre un oven
évidemment ils sont laissés sur place le
l'oven fait 500 km en 3 secondes donc il
joue pas dans la même catég un OV moi
pour voyager je te jure mais c'est un
truc de fou donc ça ça c'était déjà ça
donc tu penses qu'il vont ils vont dire
ils vont sortir un truc de fou oui je je
pense qu'il prépare quelque chose mais
je ne sais pas quoi je suis évidemment
au taquet j'ai tous mes correspondants
qui me donnent des renseignements s'ils
sont aussi présents tous les jours
toutes les semaines tous les mois pour
dire les Enis on les étudie on a mis 12
types de la NASA pour les étudier c'est
qu' il prépare quelque chose mais il
prépare quoi ça veut rien dire une
révélation s'il plat s'il te plaît merci
un truc prépare une grosse révélation
donc il prépare une grosse pourquoi que
les États-Unis dernière question et ben
voilà c'est la question que j'ai posé
tout à l'heure pourquoi il n que
lestatsis
lestatsunis a été depuis un siècle la
plus grande puissance mondiale et les
temp encore pour X temps et bien je
pense qu'ils ont réussi à approcher le
cœur du dossier et qu'ils savent ce que
sont les Enis depuis quand il n n visite
et ce qu'ils
veulent pas de fite il y a pas de fuite
il y a pas de fite F ah de fuite il y a
des fuites qui sont organisé par des
anciens des services secrets c'est tr
significatif hein tu l'as dit tout à
l'heure il y a il y a plusieurs membres
des services secrets qui sont maintenant
en dehors du système qui disent moi j'ai
été dans les services secrets et quand
j'y étais d'autres membres opérationnels
des services secrets m'ont dit on a vu
une secou volante qui s'était écrasée ce
qui est une absurdité on a vu des
extraterrestres des cadavres dans des
réfrigérateurs ce qui est une autre
absurdité mais c'est pour nous préparer
à quelque chose je pense d'accord donc
tu penses que voilà et pourtant on n'est
pas seul ah on n'est pas seul évidemment
qu'on n'est pas seul dans l'univers je
rappelle que nous sommes sur une petite
planète qui s'appelle la terre qui est
dans une galaxie qui comprend au moins
300 milliards d'étoiles et qu'il y a
2000 milliards de galaxies et qu'on en
découvre une une toutes les pratiquement
tous les jours grâce au télescope web
qui ne voit pas seulement que des poils
de cul merci merci Jeane B merci à tous
tout de suite depool 2 sur merci